هذه هي أعلى قيمة استثمارات
يمكنك القيام بها كدولة ،
ثم تدوم أطول اقتصادي
يسار ويمين الوسط
يتفقون على أن هذه استثمارات نحتاج
إلى القيام بها لتوليد نمو اقتصادي تاريخي
يتم الحفاظ عليه ليس فقط
إعادة الوظائف ولكن خلق
وظائف جديدة معًا  مع
خطة الإنقاذ الأمريكية ، ستساعد خطة الوظائف الأمريكية
الاقتصاد على
خلق كما قلت إن هناك أكثر من 16
مليون وظيفة جيدة الأجر والأشخاص الذين
لا يمكننا تحمل عدم القيام بذلك ،
لا يمكننا تحمل عدم قضاء الوقت
والجهد في
اسمحوا لي أن أشرح كيف ندفع ثمن ذلك
لأنني لست منفقًا على العجز
لأنك تعلم أن لدينا خفضًا ضريبيًا
أعاد الفريق الآخر
إعادته في 19 2017 وخلقت
عجزًا بقيمة تريليوني دولار مع
ذهاب الغالبية العظمى منه إلى
أعلى واحد على عُشر واحد في المائة من
أصحاب الأجور ،
لا أريد أن أعاقب أي شخص
يحق لك أن تكون مليونيرا أو
مليارديرًا
فقط ادفع حصتك العادلة فقط ادفع على
سبيل المثال
إذا كنا فقط  أن نتأكد من أن لدينا
معدل ضرائب لأعلى معدل في أمريكا
لضريبة الدخل ، كما كان في إدارة الأدغال
، سوف ينتقل من 36 إلى 39.6 في المائة
جيدًا ، خمن جيدًا ما سيؤدي ذلك إلى
جمع
10 مليارات دولار على الأقل سنويًا
لا أحد يؤذي
شخصًا يكسب هذا المال لا يزال
لديه منزلين أو طائرة نفاثة أو هؤلاء
هم في الغالب من أصحاب الملايين
ولن يتأذوا قليلاً